paris s'il vous plaît merci voilà
un lever de rideau attendu par
guyancourt et saint quentin en yvelines
après dix mois de travaux le nouveau
parc des sources de la bièvre s'est
dévoilé de 1600 mètres cubes de remblais
pour combler l'ancienne fontaine mais
aussi un espace de street workout 240
mètres carrés cette inauguration surtout
les travaux on les attendait depuis
assez longtemps maintenant on avait
refait semaille des sols qui est
magnifique alors certes il a été
totalement terminée l'an dernier mais
les travaux ont duré près de trois ans
et puis on avait cette petite partie là
entre le maïdo sol et la roseraie mari
de mme anne marie do qui restait un
espace a également été inaugurée sous le
nom de place de la république
aujourd'hui en plus anniversaire de la
vème république
je crois que c'était important et c'est
important effectivement notamment et on
nous l'a fait remarquer que cette place
et une plaque et une plaque bien
visibles parmi les vocations de ce parc
rénové l'environnement avec la
plantation d'une soixantaine d'arbres
c'est un beau symbole
donc de 2,2 de végétalisation de
l'espace pour faire du sport et dieu
sait si guyancourt dans saint quentin va
aussi être porteur de ce merveilleux
message international mondial que que
sont les jeux olympiques de stimuler les
gens à faire du sport à se bouger à se
promener à achat de la compétition des
travaux soutenus par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines qui ont coûté
800 10000 euros au total